that's where I think we can safely say
every point that needs to be made has
been made although not by every single
speaker we all know exactly what is
needed to make a good deal here in Paris
we need a deal that keeps two degrees
alive a deal with a binding legal
mechanism a deal that has a five-year
review so we can see how we're doing a
deal for the poorest and most vulnerable
countries in terms of finance a deal so
that we can measure and verify what
happens with the agreement that we make
and a deal that transfers technology
from the richest countries to the
poorest countries so let me in my three
minutes take this argument the other way
round not what we need to succeed we all
know that but let's just imagine for a
moment what we would have to say to our
grandchildren if we failed
we'd have to say it was all too
difficult and they would reply well what
was so difficult what was it that was so
difficult when the earth was in peril
when the sea levels were rising in 2015
when crops were failing when deserts
were expanding what was it that was so
difficult was it difficult to agree on
two degrees was it difficult when 97% of
scientists the world over have said that
climate change is urgent and man-made
and must be addressed when there are
over 4,000 pieces of literature and
reviews making exactly this point why
was they would ask us sticking to two
degrees at least above industrial levels
so difficult presumably we might have to
say well it was difficult to reach a
binding agreement but they would ask us
why is it difficult to reach a legally
binding agreement when in 2015 there are
already 75 countries including countries
across most of the continents of our
world that already have legally binding
climate change legislation countries
like Britain and countries that aren't
spring from having legally-binding
climate change legislation some
countries that are thriving with that
legislation perhaps we'd have to argue
it was too difficult to have a review
after five years why they would ask us
is it difficult to have a review after
five years no one is being asked to
pre-ordained what that review would say
no one is being asked to sign up to
automatic decreases in their carbon
emissions if we're off track in five
years time a review isn't difficult
perhaps we'd have to say it was too
difficult to reach agreement about
finance
too difficult to get to a hundred
billion dollars of climate finance by
2020 but how could we argue to our
grandchildren that it was difficult
where we've already managed to generate
sixty two billion dollars by 2014 how
can we argue it's difficult when in
London alone there's five trillion
dollars of funds and the management and
we haven't even really begun to generate
the Private Finance that is possible to
help in tackling climate change they
will ask us was it really too difficult
to agree to a mechanism to measure and
verify what you'd all sign up to how can
that be so difficult that we agree that
over time we must make sure that we're
delivering on the things that we said
we'd deliver here in Paris and finally
would we really be able to argue that it
was too difficult too difficult to
transfer technology from rich countries
to poorer countries our grandchildren
would rightly ask us what was so
difficult you had this technology you
knew it worked you knew that if you gave
it to poor and vulnerable countries they
could pregnant protect themselves
against climate change why on earth
didn't you do it all I'm saying is that
instead of making excuses tomorrow to
our children and grandchildren we should
be taking action against climate change
today what we're looking at is not
difficult it is doable
therefore we should come together and do
it thank you